even at my age at 35 I'm wearing some
big white [ __ ] mom underwear really
well I mean most of the time when
there's no man around I don't know my
mom and I share underwear like when I
everybody
what
there have been times where I visited
and I forgot to pack underwear and she
wears thongs
okay so I still have some of her
underwear I'm like
my mom happy when she was 22 so it's not
like she still hit me at 18 I would
never so she's like underwear so that's
sad for you and no
foreign
[Music]
I came from Austin I came from Nevada
very far flight different states what I
always say three different states four
different states different rates of
depression State of California there you
go see what we have here we might
actually be in just three states though
yeah
um or one or one or often being once a
depression
we're not that far from each other or we
might just all be in the same room in
one state yeah there you go
um it's us us forward if Jess Gina Nikki
and we're gonna we're gonna do what I
love doing the most judging people so
it's another episode of uh am I the
[ __ ] because I can't get enough of
these and like I like thinking about
other people being worse than me so also
I don't know I could be wrong but I I
think this might be the first one that
all four of us are in the uh
because you haven't done am I the
[ __ ] not here I mean we do it on our
show but I don't think I've done it here
no no
right
everyone's doing it yeah okay let's get
started I'm so excited I love you so
much and I pulled up so many and I'm
reading this uh for the first time I
just pulled uh titles that sounded
interesting so I'm going into this blind
with you guys and we're all gonna react
to this together
um and then chat you are free chat sorry
I'm not streaming
viewers you guys are free to leave
comments on how you feel about it too
okay the first one is am I the [ __ ]
for leaving my wife by herself when she
talks in a cringy matter hmm what oh boy
here we go I think I know where Nikki's
going on this one who wants to guess
what kind of do leave me alone I have
much more interesting conversations
myself but oh yeah with your inside
voices
hello my name is Nikki oh God I totally
forgot
like this
what do you think where does your tongue
go yeah how do you pronounce the m
without your lips exactly I don't know
or it's nice she's saying 19 is Nikki
[Music]
that's an M how can you shop please get
me out of here I'm so scared
dude
with your own mouth yeah I didn't have
friends so like it was just me and my
inside friends I've heard you do like
I've witnessed this before but every
time
you experience I was talking about it
too yeah why have you not done a tick
tock about this I'm not sure
yesterday I was I mean earlier I was
wsitting and I'm just a freak all around
yeah yeah
I love you thank you I'm alone
well it's not so much fun I know okay
that's probably not what his wife's
doing though I would marry her even
harder if she knew how to do that that's
crazy I know it's such a cool Talent
yeah so I don't know like it kind of
reminds me of uh Emma the [ __ ] that
we did yesterday where like this girl
used a new voice or no a relationship
but anyways she used a new voice when
she was talking to a person like a guy
that she likes oh no
so anyway that's what kind of reminds me
so maybe like his wife has like a cringy
voice that only comes out during certain
times yeah like you know what I'm at or
imagine she comes out with a funny ass
silly voice when they're fighting oh my
God or like I can't imagine it being a
baby voice because that's a pretty
common thing for relationships and he
should have known of that early on in
the relationship not married so yeah
curious to know what kind of voice
am I the [ __ ] for leaving my wife by
herself when she talks in a cringy
manner cringy Manor maybe she starts
getting all like like on a soapbox or
something I don't know she's like she's
like she goes hashtag hustle uh hashtag
rise and grind hashtag stop he's like
all right and he closes he goes back to
bed a lot of people OMG WTF has the like
fake uh air fried vocals like
my old firm that would talk like this
and I was like just [ __ ] just talk
it's a thing now it's a thing in your
throat and talk yeah
literally everything is like what like
no way okay
so I was going to get some food the
other day yeah and then they ran out of
my food and it's like I learned about
that in Family Guy he's a little [ __ ] I
notice it now there's there's this thing
where like guys would try to sound sexy
and have a deep voice like I just love
it what a woman yeah do you need a
lozenge are you okay
resell something oh I feed where it was
a guy talking like that uh it's talking
about like yeah so when a woman like
blah blah and then like they cut it oh
yeah with the dog it was like a dog like
whaling like
[Laughter]
I don't sound like those people have to
use those voice models
scene everyone can tell that you're
faking a deep voice it's so funny weird
all right see with how this lady talks
ever since we 27 year old uh ever since
we had a baby my wife had been talking
like a baby herself oh baby he hates it
rather than teaching the baby to talk
like a person it's as if my wife's
language oh that's also really really
really detrimental for your baby's
development and language you're not
supposed to talk like when you go
that doesn't help your baby
though where like you elongate or where
you go like do you want to eat like
you're kind of like talking like a baby
but that's actually encouraged to help
your baby learn language because you're
like you're exaggerating yeah you're
exaggerating the enunciations of the
word you can understand that yeah so
then you can learn it but if it's like
Google gaga stuff then that that hurts
your child I'm gonna start talking to
Luca in like business
like are you hungry no okay let's Circle
back on this later yeah
per my last email Luca stop throwing up
on my bed
okay so rather than teaching the baby to
talk like a person it's as if my wife's
language has become baby-like she would
make noises in between conversations
like
oh yeah even when we're talking about
how did you do that yeah
it's a rapper's name somewhere [ __ ]
and she does it even when talking with
adults no yeah that's not she kind of
they sucked a little too many vitamins
yeah she used to keep taking her
prenatals and also she needs more like
adult time yeah sounds like she's only
with baby she spends 24 hours with Bob
the Builder Coco melon all day it's
finally yeah positive Builders old now
it's our old reference I don't know
children's things
I have a an infant and I would have said
um let's see this is especially
embarrassing when I'm with her in public
when she talks like that to complete
strangers
why would you do this he is not the
[ __ ] yeah no I don't even need to
hear the rest of it oh my god well he is
if he's not getting her help yeah yeah
I've been telling her nicely not to do
that but she would just laugh it off
totally oblivious to how people around
us there whenever she talks like a baby
I have to point out that she is not in
the Spectrum just a crazy new mom too
crazy sometimes
does he know that for sure
it was a day off for us when we had my
parents babysitting the baby and we
finally have some time by ourselves we
went out for dinner and she'd done it
again talking to the waiter done it
again she goddamn done it again
and he's like God damn it James you've
done it again
[Applause]
I'm out of here it probably makes him
sound like a pedophile yeah
oh my God they're into some Kink stuff
yeah she is
he's not having it uh so she did again
talking to the waiter something like
this quote thanks yeah
oh well yeah yeah yeah by the way can
you give us an extra plate for this you
want the whole anime yeah she was like
full it's like an anime
oh [ __ ] oh whoa well yeah yeah by the
way can you give us an extra shot
that's embarrassing seeing how the
waiter's staring at her as if she's some
kind of mentally challenged kid they
rolled my eyes and I told her I am
taking a break today and don't need
another baby who cannot even talk
properly to look after yeah please
excuse me then I left the restaurant
without her I don't know what occurred
to me but I probably shouldn't have done
that but I guess I kind of just snapped
am I the [ __ ] no wait how did the
white first one that's what I want to
know yeah me too I wouldn't leave her in
a restaurant especially like he didn't
say if he's had conversations exactly he
did he did say oh wait um I've been
telling her nicely not to do that but
she would just laugh it off totally
oblivious to help people around us there
whenever she talks like a baby maybe it
wasn't like serious enough like maybe it
was kind of yeah she was kind of like I
was like you think I'm cute yeah yeah
yeah
approach where it didn't like he didn't
make it all the money that's that's
weird that you do that in front of
people now huh yeah
Yoshi spins up
yeah I'm wondering if he actually like
really sat around like hey this is not
okay it's not normal
um I would say kind of leaving her in a
restaurant kind of a lot
I don't know if I can leave mice yeah
but I think I don't know I don't I
understand like if it's just been weeks
or months even I've heard being this
[ __ ] weirdo yeah yeah it's still like
I would probably get up and watch the
mother too
I would have a conversation first yeah
with her like make sure no seriously you
need to stop exactly and then if she's
still like doing it then I'm like okay
I'm gonna go yeah I would give a warning
yeah a warning
next time this happens I'm sorry but I
will need to walk away because this is
too much yeah this reminds me of this
guy that I went on a couple dates with
and
you know when people are just not funny
yep and they just like their sense of
humor it's like what the [ __ ] like
so I oh boy here we go uh we went to a
grocery store it was a mitsua like a
Japanese store if you guys don't know
that and
um we were standing at the register
um paying for stuff and he's like you
want to see something funny I'm like he
goes he grabs a bag of chips he goes why
won't you get me this oh I'm done oh my
gosh just like threw it on the floor and
just walked out because he thought it
was funny like a prank call you know oh
God it's so cute cringed I've never
cringed so my vagina just went yeah
inside to my belly button yeah right
like I want to just die there and also
it makes it way less like if it was a
prank it's even like wait a minute yeah
that he said like you want to see
something buddy yeah and I just don't I
don't think being loud and like just
aggressive like a teenager yeah it's
like literally a 14 year old yeah it's a
teenager that's not comedy to me no like
it was just so I looked at it I was like
what the [ __ ] and he stormed off and I
looked at the um cashier he was looking
at me and I was like those [ __ ] weird
like the hell was that I wasn't
embarrassed I was like oh my God don't
look at me it was more like the [ __ ] was
that yeah like you saw that right like
yeah I'm not crazy yeah it was weird
yeah I was like that would I would never
talk about I would have been embarrassed
but for him yeah like yeah no I would be
embarrassed that our second person yeah
I'm like this reflects on me I was
literally hanging out with this cringy
[ __ ] dumbass yeah yeah and then so I
I like just paid for myself this was a
date uh this was like in between dates
okay you know yeah it's like you were
going like you were seeing him yeah this
is like a made you pay for your own [ __ ]
too
that's not that's not well I was just
buying stuff or whatever grab some stuff
and then so like I was paid for myself
he came back in like oh and I was like
he came back
like walking up and down the sidewalk
around the outside waiting for me like
oh yeah like commit to the joke I guess
I'll come back in like I'm ready to
battle performance
wasn't that great dude it would be
better if he just drove off and left
yeah I would feel better if I went to
the parking lot yeah
commit to it drive into the ocean please
holy [ __ ] but I guess like the way he
set it up though we should have expected
this ending yeah right so what'd you
think that's good
yeah so he came in like and I was like
what was that he's like oh it wasn't
funny I'm like no not really that was
weird dude yeah that didn't last
weird no thank God I said did you sleep
with that guy no like I can't imagine he
had the energy the big dick energy
right there and then like he did like
the the um that was funny right
and I'm like all right
it just gets worse and worse
any school
right you just had a little pat on the
head
um so the comments say okay so what
what's you guys's consensus is he an
[ __ ] or no well for the for the
walking out
his feelings aren't asked yeah right
yeah
maybe a different it would have a little
bit of a conversation first before
like walking out yeah exactly so the
consensus on uh Reddit and the top
comment is uh Esh everyone sucks here
everybody sucks uh did you get a
restaurant is unkind and a little
dramatic talking to complete strangers
and a baby voice is crazy and
embarrassing I don't blame you at all
for being frustrated and walking away
but she's your wife yeah and sometimes
people we love are imperfect try to
react with kindness she's probably an
exhausted walking zombie right now that
being said her behavior she's got all
that [ __ ] energy for that weirdness
she's delusional yeah exactly like how
she's so tired she's delusional right
um that being said her behavior is weird
and atypical for new moms I'd have a
sit-down conversation and let her laugh
it off if she starts brushing it off
again I'd say quote I'm not joking this
is a strange behavior and that's really
starting to worry me make it crystal
clear that you're disturbed and if she
persists to tell her you're not
interested in a date night until she can
act like an adult I would say she needs
to go to therapy maybe yeah if she
doesn't take it seriously she's not like
Okay so Ariel stop it yeah like if
that's not the first [ __ ] thing out
of her mouth she needs to go to therapy
yes that's what I'm saying she's gonna
drown the baby or something there's
something in there that's not clicking
like dress it up still yeah yeah and
she'll try to read it she'll [ __ ]
pretty bird that [ __ ] yeah yeah
do they not know [ __ ] that's old
um another comment says we need more
info how long ago did your wife have the
baby and who's the primary caregiver
because if your wife is basically at
home with a newborn all the time not
getting enough adult interaction that
speaks to a bigger problem than you
being embarrassed and acting in a cringy
manner who the [ __ ] ditches their wife
to teach him a lesson yeah that was too
far that's not an adult way to handle it
either they are meant for each other but
people are saying like she might be
going through some mental stuff right
now like post birth and stuff
um another one says you are the [ __ ]
I get that it's embarrassing but I think
how your wife feels to be ditched but
think about how your wife feels me
ditched in a public setting uh the other
thing is that you just assume she's
purposely doing this there are several
different psychological medical reasons
that might be behind this whoa yeah yeah
that's nice I know like I mean I know
this isn't selling it to you women that
don't have children but it definitely
changes you like having a child going
through birth it changes you and ways
that many people don't expect like one
weird ass side effect or symptom or
whatever that I had after Isaac was I I
no longer was able to tell like how long
time had passed like the time relativity
or whatever it's called yeah
to this day I struggled with that like I
can't really tell you like oh yeah like
an hour ago this happened or like or I
fed Luca 10 minutes ago that's why I
have to keep track of of when he had a
diaper change when he I fed him when he
slept like I don't trust my own
yeah I can't and that happened after
Isaac yeah like it's just been it was
the weirdest thing ever like you never
hear that right yeah you never hear
someone going through that kind of
symptom after having a kid like it's
weird so maybe for her it's like
something clicked in her head or
hormonally or something where like this
is the way she speaks now also have you
guys heard of the cat lady disease yeah
yeah but yeah I wonder if they have a
cat because it sounds like the same
symptoms yeah explain it for other
people so like something to do with the
kitty litter if there's like a Paris
It's Like A Parasite yeah I don't know
the exact
science behind I just the reason why I
know is because there's a documentary
right no I recently read about it
because when I was pregnant that's like
a warning like don't handle kitty litter
don't handle kitty poop because kitty
poop has this this parasite in it that
can turn you crazy like yeah yeah and it
makes you talk to yourself and do all
the like the crazy cat lady meme is like
actually like a parasite that like made
them like that yeah so like really like
be careful about touching your face
after like scooping the litter or like
like wash your hands thoroughly like
don't like accidentally like scratch
your nose or whatever yeah I don't know
how it gets in there like I think like
getting through your eye ducks and it
can get through your nose and stuff yeah
yeah whoa that's crazy
crazy I'm trying to think but it makes
you go
yeah all right no I have cleaners you're
literally talking to yourself like do
you know have you had these symptoms
yeah
I need 12 more
research shows that sex is as mental as
it is physical so you need more than
just an amazing vibrator if you always
go to that same sexy chapter in a
romance novel or you have a particular
scene in a movie you always think about
Dipsy can help you get there in a new
way with Dipsy you can skip straight to
the good parts Dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and realistic characters
find stories about an intriguing
co-worker with a British accent or
hooking up with your hot yoga instructor
Dipsy also has stories for queer
listeners and 56 of stories are voice
acted by people of color new content is
released every week so in between
listening to your favorite stories again
and again you can always find something
new to explore let Dipsy be your go-to
place to spice up your me time explore
your fantasies relax and unwind or even
heat things up with a partner for
listeners of this show dibs he's
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com mood
that's 30 days of full access for free
when you go to d i p s e a
stories.com mood that's dipsystories.com
mood okay uh the next one is um am I the
[ __ ] for literally showing my dad how
he behaves every day when he gets home
from work
um
I am 16 years old female my father is a
46 year old male my father is a
breadwinner while mom is a stay-at-home
mom she handles everything around the
house at cooking mopping washing laundry
Etc I'm the oldest and I try to help but
there's only so much I can do while my
dad just gets home at the end of the day
it literally complains about everything
like how the carpet isn't clean or how
the food is cold
as a result I'd have to list I'd have to
listen to a huge argument daily between
him and Mom it's exhausting but honestly
I think that my dad is in the wrong here
yeah
I tried talking to get him to know how
to see how his behavior is but to know
available to no avail
so what I did was pick a day off for him
and pretend to act like him I put
together an outfit that looked like a
suit put black tape over my lips it
looked like a little mustache at 6 PM I
went inside the house and shouted I'm
home I've been sat next time in the
living room and started kicking my shoes
while complaining about the state of the
house at the top of my lungs he glanced
at me confused asking what I was doing I
ignored him then started yelling about
the carpet being dirty shower not ready
the kids needing to be quiet and so on
he kept staring while mom and my
siblings laughed my youngest brother
kept pointing towards me saying this is
Daddy I then proceeded to yell about
dinner then berated my mom for not
preparing it before time my dad stopped
me and in serious tone asked what I was
doing I turned to him and said what
can't a man effing rest after working
long hours in the most Macho voice I
could muster my dad got the hint because
this was a common phrase he used daily
he went quiet and avoided looking at me
I stopped the act and told him I was
trying to show him what he's like every
day when he comes home from work he said
nothing just went outside and refused to
talk to me later he went on about how I
mocked and invalidated him that he does
hard or work hard and me doing this was
disrespectful and invalidating Mom said
it was funny but also thought I hurt my
dad's feelings and I could have gotten
the message across some other way
instead I agree with the mom like what
that hurt the Dad's feeling yeah it's
like accurate yes uh gets the point
across yes but it could have been done a
little bit more respectfully I suppose
those and especially with a guy like
that I don't think he's gonna receive
the message so it's kind of just doing
it for the rest of the family that's
like yeah that is like humiliating yeah
it's more humiliating and then coming
from the child too yeah to the the dad
is it's even more humiliating it'd be
like if she had tried to have a
conversation with him first and he's
like I don't get it no this is bad like
blah blah I'm valid and then she's like
do you want me to show you what you're
like when you come home and then like
did it like I think that would kind of
he'd be more receptive and in a
receiving mode but to just kind of like
yeah Blindside him like that I don't
think he'll ever get the message in fact
I think he might even turn away from
that so this kid did say that he tried
to talk to his dad about it multiple
times and it never worked so I don't
understand why the mom is not able to
like reach a an agreement with her
husband over like generally what time he
wants his food cooked fine like this
this is her job right being the
housewife so I will have food ready by
seven why do we need to argue about that
again yeah um I will have like X these
chores done on Monday these on Wednesday
these on Friday like why is there still
fights every single day it's not like
children have to get involved sounds
like there's younger children involved
so like this is a 16 year old but she's
like by far the oldest yeah so when
there's younger children involved as
much as you want to have something done
on this specific time like it's just not
it doesn't happen right on schedule and
that's the part that the guy doesn't
understand because he's at work in a
corporate setting with adults where
everything can be done diligently and on
time so he comes home why can't it be
ready when I on this on this hour and
it's like well because the [ __ ] kids
like there's like a lot of [ __ ] going on
that like you just can't get it done in
town like you're dealing with adults
that have scheduled and you know stuff
at work but at home you have [ __ ]
Psychopaths running around yeah and
things happen so that's so true yeah the
best part to that because I've been
trying to get on a schedule it's it's
[ __ ] impossible yeah it's hard
children under two like yeah that's
really impossible yeah but the best
thing would be like if he could do her
job for a day just to see what it's like
like you tried getting dinner ready at
six like just to see just so you know
how hard it is it's not just like well
you're sitting at home all day because
that's the whole meme is like like
you're just sitting at home all day uh
what what a luxury I have to go to work
and my hard job and you get to just sit
at home all day it's like that's how
she's doing yeah I personally like how
he did this because I uh it's a guy
where it's a girl uh that the 16 year
old is a girl yeah I grew up in a family
like this where like
um my grandfather just come home and
Grumble Grumble Grumble like really
Asian
um he's not happy he just wasn't happy
yeah because that's if you're happy
you're not gonna come home and do that
yeah he's just not happy with it yeah
and it's like a very like man of the
house why didn't you do this why didn't
you do blah blah and like just it was
very it was too much like literally like
yeah my stepdad was like that yeah and
it's just like bro shut the [ __ ] up like
shut the [ __ ] up you know like it's it's
it's hard being a stay-at-home mom with
so many kids and having to balance all
this but like to come home like you're
not even grateful at all yeah you know
and to like not even try to help you
know like oh like do you need help like
I'll put I'll put the plates out for
dinner or whatever like just something
little but for you to crumble angry kick
and feet off I worked hard all days all
right bubble like that [ __ ] off you know
like this is a family you guys are
supposed to be working together if you
have a different agreement like whatever
but like still show some sort of
gratitude yeah you know towards your
wife instead of being a dick every time
you come home yeah because I remember my
family having to walk on eggshells like
dreading the time that he comes home
from work yeah like even if dinner was
perfect or whatever there was still
something always wrong always wrong yeah
and it's just like such he's like
looking for it right it's like he almost
like made it part of his routine to like
look for sure I just I don't it's hard
for me to understand why that would go
on for so long it's like if you don't
like if if you're unhappy at your job if
someone's cheating on you all day long
and that's why you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] when you come home and want to [ __ ]
on it like it's like something has to
like where's the communication where's
the where's the fix for this terribly
unhappy life and if he's just that guy
yeah why do you want to keep your kids
in that situation like why do you want
to like why would you like I don't know
I just don't I don't understand why
people want to live like that for so
long yeah and allow that to continue a
lot of times they feel like there
there's the options are limited you know
like if she's staying home all day she
doesn't have a job so then she if she
was to leave him she's gonna have to try
to find a job and find someone yeah to
watch the kids and so that's like the
situation is hard when you're married
with kids and you're in an unhappy
situation
um you know just from couples I know
that like
we're not having a good time together
but like they're kids involved it's like
yeah but there's I can't go anywhere or
like if I do it's gonna be just a lot
harder than trying to put up with this
for a couple years more years I think
it's like the the attitude of it too
it's like if he comes home and he's just
like really frustrating she really isn't
doing anything I can understand why he
would be like dude what the hell you
know like but it doesn't say his
daughter is saying that she's doing
everything yeah yeah but it's the
daughter asking if she's the [ __ ] I I
think she kind of was like I don't feel
like exactly what Nikki has said like if
she had she did try having conversations
and then she said she proposed would you
like for me to show you yeah what you
look like
so let me show you what you look like
but the mom's like the mom's saying like
yeah you got the point you could have
done this and uh you could have sent the
message in a different way too like yeah
I don't know how she tried talking to
her dad maybe her dad's super hard to
talk to and this felt like the only like
the last resort kind of thing it's a
difficult situation but just from the
outside like the surface part I would
say yeah she's an [ __ ] that's the
vibe I'm getting it's like he's one of
those people that does not listen or
take any sort of like talks like that
and is actually receptive to it so this
was like a Hail Mary yeah I think at 16
like she was trying to stick up for her
family and so I I I like the intention
behind it but I I just don't think it it
was done in a way that helps that party
that she's trying to fix yeah all right
so consensus on um Reddit says not the
[ __ ] he held up a mirror to his
behavior and he didn't like what he saw
and that's on him I hope he gets the
message he didn't even realize he was
looking in the mirror until he end then
all the feelings crashed down hard on
him and hopefully he'll learn
um good job on figuring out a method
that eliminated the situation
the second comment says not the [ __ ]
first off but I think you have a good
chance here listen please you can
acknowledge quote Hey Dad I know that
probably her did hurt your feelings and
I'm sorry of course you work hard and
provide us and we appreciate it but I
want you to see that your behavior hurts
mom's feelings and hurts the family the
fact that he went quiet instead of
exploding in Anger to me says that there
is hope like many many dudes his age he
struggles to process these emotions but
he recognize he was feeling more
embarrassed and slashed hurt than angry
it seems the keys to understand and
withhold judgment to re-enter the convo
on not just his pain but everyone's
feeling everyone feeling pain and move
forward that's tough you're a kid it's
not irresponsible to do it you would be
morally Justified to say [ __ ] off but I
always ask do you want to win or be
right being right often feels hello I
hope you win yeah oh yeah not the
[ __ ] this is genius you didn't hear
your words or your mom's words so many
times you both told him the issues
instead you made him watch himself and
people don't like when Amir is up to
their actions and it's not your job to
help regulate your parents emotions if
your dad feels bad that's on him your
other methods fell on deaf ears this one
appeared to hit home good for you I
agree with them because I've I hate
dealing with people who just don't
listen it's like all right then you're
just gonna have to learn the hard way
and if you have to get embarrassed into
learning it then that's on you yeah
that's a good point to bring up though
how he reacted at the end and he kept
saying like what are you doing yeah
because I thought the what are you doing
was like a warning to her yeah what are
you doing you better stop like I know
what you're doing you better [ __ ]
check yourself but yeah the final
response of like oh it clicked and then
he shut down that's a good thing to
point out because yeah like maybe
they're that did come across to him and
hopefully he changes after that yeah
sometimes people gotta learn the hard
way and then the fact that he's a little
kid the youngest one even said huh Daddy
Daddy it's like oh [ __ ] yeah like that's
definitely yeah that's very very clear
all right uh next one
um am I the answer for getting my aunt
and uncle kicked out of their house for
not letting my husband and I sleep
together
oh wow how the hell
okay sounds like immediately yeah
I'm a male 27 and married to a man 28
years old he is the love of my life I've
only oh God I can see where this is
going home I'd only ever dated women
before him but when I realized or when I
met him I realized I was bi and we fell
in love we got married in the fall of
2018 so it's been almost four years and
we now live in Vermont God I forget that
that's a state sometime
I don't know it's a little bigger but
yeah not very big Rhode Island is the
tiniest one right yes we're just there
and it felt kind of big-ish sort of I
don't know my old family is from a small
town in Texas oh boy a super
conservative Catholic area oh boy
um I was raised there but Dad got a job
in New York City when I was 15. the
culture shock was difficult we went from
living in rural Texas to living in an
apartment in Manhattan my parents didn't
sell our house in Texas they allowed our
aunt and uncle who just had their third
child to move in while charging them a
small rent in college when I came out as
bi my brother and dad were very
supportive my mom needed some time to
accept uh the rest of my family reacted
poorly at first but came around during
visits we stayed with my aunt and uncle
at my old house but because we weren't
married we weren't allowed to share a
bed we didn't argue but we both would
rather make peace visiting since instead
of staying with aunt and uncle we would
rent a motel room during covid we did
not visit them but this summer my
parents and bro decided to go visit my
hometown again for two weeks and invited
my husband and I I went to I wanted the
motel again but my aunt Uncle insisted
my brother husband and I stay with them
yeah the first night sleeping situation
was being discussed after my cousins
went to bed my aunt and uncle wanted me
and brother to take the spare bedroom
husband on the couch all three of us
took issue with that they snapped that
we were not really married because we
were gay and that they had children in
the house wow
with no butt [ __ ] when there's kids
in here like they can't [ __ ] chill
out for one night yeah right and why is
it going in your bedroom like you just
had a third kid oh my god
um that's it they would stay to the
motel though exactly why insist that
said that's a humiliate they wanted to
bring them in the house to force them to
not have sex yeah like I don't want you
[ __ ] in the motel room either you get
no butt sex oh [ __ ] in this city
um they said that it would be a bad
influence on their kids this hurt my
husband's feeling he started crying and
ran out of the room when my husband ran
out my uncle had the audacity start
laughing that's when I saw red ew dude
yeah I would see red too yikes
I started cussing them out so loudly
that my young cousins came to
investigate I told them that if they
didn't go apologize to my husband
immediately then I was going to tell my
dad what just happened and I was gonna
make sure to have them kicked out of the
house that was still in my parents name
my brother seconded everything that I
was saying they started backtracking and
saying that they were that we were still
welcomed in quote their house but that
we had to follow their rules I responded
that it wasn't really their house I told
them they were going to be homeless if I
had it my way the kids started crying
because they heard me say that they were
all going to be homeless so we left my
husband was on the porch crying I
promised him that I would never subject
him to that again I told Dad what
happened to say that my dad was angry
would be an understatement he served
them a notice of eviction for 60 days
wow oh that's a good death yeah yeah
well I'm mad at it yeah I've been
getting calls and texts and Facebook
messages from my family calling me an
[ __ ] I want to know am I the answer
[ __ ] for allowing my young cousins to
end up homeless is it fair that they
have to pay for what my aunt and uncle
said to me
you have no [ __ ] income like you're
you're in this situation so much yeah
why is so why is everyone else taking
care of your [ __ ] yeah
and the famous irresponsible of getting
kicked out and not having a home you put
your homophobia over them yes exactly or
the safety you couldn't even apologize
yeah all he said is go apologize
and they were like no our house our
rules yeah like that's yeah the fact
that he laughed when the husband was
crying is like so it's like evil it's
disgusting it is it's malicious it's
gross I'm pretty sure like the this
guy's parents won't let anything happen
to the like the cousins yeah like the
kids or whatever you know what I mean
it's just like but the parents need to
learn a lesson yeah everyone's says not
the [ __ ] and I love your dad yeah
yeah me too not the [ __ ] the insisted
Hotel was not needed and then decided to
disregard your marriage the whole not
married so separate rooms thing was
clearly an excuse before as well it's
entirely your father's decision on who
to let live in the house and you're well
within your rights to tell him what
happened yeah just because he reacted as
you expected him to doesn't make you an
[ __ ] yeah that's pretty clear-cut I
love that Dad me too that's so awesome
the next one is
am I the [ __ ] for not saying anything
about the underwear
underwear okay oh I thought this was the
same one I was like I don't know next
one well yeah
[Laughter]
in the front no because I pictured a
thong but like in the center where the
butthole is it's like a circle
it's a ring it up perfectly yeah on the
butthole looks pretty dope totally
unnecessary you just move it to the side
hey look at you don't take it off
instead of all the fabric it could be
like a [ __ ] ring thing yeah plastic
there you go yeah stretches yeah
my dick got stuck in your phone
perfect
[Applause]
you remember in Joe Dirt where like the
dog's balls get stuck to the porch
Dick's like pulling the song really far
back because it's stuck
don't get sorry
sexy balls sexy balls oh my God you got
a front wedgie
ouch okay cowers is stupid okay
what color was it that you guys were
picturing I was picturing like blue with
red light blue with a blue with a pink
ring oh that's funny I was picturing
glittery pink for some reason oh I like
that I don't know why are we designing
this stuff
the underwear was red and then the ring
was like at first it was like a like a
metal Silver pretty one I'm like wait no
it needs to be able to stretch so yeah
it's like rubber yeah rubber yeah they
do it like silver rubber like silver or
silicone you've seen that yeah anyway
what color was it for you I didn't
picture a color I just pictured the
object colorless like now being like
well you have to be able to snap the
ring off because yeah
I'm thinking buttons on the side yeah
how like you close you have your butt
cheeks closed and there's a ring there
yeah
your butt cheeks just always okay we
spent way too much yeah it's just like
sitting on there
like a [ __ ] pad yeah I swear to God
it's like a spacer yeah
but five years from now I see this on
the internet being sold I'm gonna be
pissed you know what a few years ago I
said I want to invent something like to
put on my wrist or something for when I
wash my face because I [ __ ] hate how
it always drips on my elbows now they
have those scrunchy thingies I'm like I
[ __ ] thought of that right but they
have the ones that just fold up yeah
does your probiotic contain clinically
studied strains meet one that does
Rachel's symbiotic plus contains two of
the world's most studied strains with
over 350 publications of human clinical
trials I chose ritual symbiotic plus
because it makes me feel healthier and
as a woman it just makes my body feel a
lot better so what makes the component
so clearly ritual there are signs back
in research stacked especially when
stacked up against the leading Direct
customer and top selling probiotics on
the market it's also more than just
probiotic it's three in one with
clinically studied prebiotics probiotics
and postbiotic to support a balanced gut
microbiome it's also just one minty
capsule it tastes like mint tastes so
good all you need is one daily capsule
for simple streamlined gut Support also
you don't need to refrigerate this like
other probiotics it's designed with a
moisture controlled bottle technology to
protect probiotic strains symbiotic plus
and ritual are here to celebrate not
hide your insides there is no more shame
in your gut game that's why ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
big mood to start ritual or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today once again that's ritual.com big
moon to get 10 off during your first
three months okay
uh no more butthole talk well kind of
yeah right am I the [ __ ] for not
saying anything small is the same thing
that's true that's right just broke your
own
um okay so my idea is a butthole am I
the butthole for not saying anything
about the underwear uh my 20 year old
daughter and her fiance are currently
staying with us I love my daughter but
she's very difficult and I can't stand
her fiance I gave them a deadline and
move out because I can't take this
anymore the Dad or Mom
I have no idea okay big onto a massive
fight the other day while my wife was
out okay
um I guess a pair of my wife's underwear
got in the laundry and I got into their
laundry and she thought he was cheating
I think the fact she immediately jumped
to cheating shows how bad their
relationship is yeah which kind of
underwear is his wife wearing I mean
she's still wearing well it's ring in
the back it's red
because I picture like but even at my
age at 35 I'm wearing some big white
[ __ ] mom underwear really because
like well I mean most of the time when
there's no man around I don't know my
mom and I share underwear like when I
everybody
what there have been times where I
visited and I forgot to pack underwear
and she wears thongs
okay so I still have some of her
underwear I'm like
my mom had me when she was 22 so it's
not like she feels like me at 18 I would
never she's like yeah well that's sad
for you and no
I don't want anything
near my genitals I've been that close to
my parents generally yeah well anyway I
guess I didn't really think about it I
was just like I didn't bring it
underwear and she's like I got some buy
some then she has like cute ones from
Victoria's Secret and I'm like man I
like that I mean I'm happy for you that
you're that close to your mom that's
cute but I wonder like how yeah the
daughter so the fiance or whatever sees
a pair of these moms sexy [ __ ]
underwear and immediately assumes wait
is it her mom or is it it's her mom it's
her mom it's mother-in-law right no her
mom no it's her own mom yeah because
he's underwear because the Dad wrote my
wife yeah
I guess yeah I wouldn't freak out right
away because like I mean I am sure if
you're in a house with other women yeah
dude underwear and our dryer that isn't
mine and uh people stay the night it
could have been yeah so it seems like
please ask the big mood girls if it's
one of theirs because are any of you
missing like red lace underwear no maybe
oh it might be okay so if any if if it
was any of us and I would point the
finger around because she keeps leaving
things everywhere yeah so I would
definitely thinking so like I I didn't
even know
tiny part of me was like were you
cheating not like even a slate little
you wouldn't be doing it and find the
underwear either where did you find the
underwear it was in the dryer no but
like how did it even get there well I
was doing laundry and then like how did
her underwear getting your laundry well
it could have been like because it was
after we did a few shoots like so it
could have been I don't know if you
change your address if it's just in the
room and they start picking up stuff
yeah or even if you can walk down the
hallway and it fell somehow like and
then Steve's like underwear I guess I'll
put this one he'd be like on Nicki
Steve I swear to God if you sniff my
friend's underwear thinking that it's
mine yes I will kill you kill you
all smells like
oh geez just deny that it was yours but
I was like I I was like damn like purple
if you were cheating on me I can't even
be mad because like I feel so loved I
feel so cherished like I don't feel like
any of my needs are not met so I I don't
even good job
that's ridiculous yeah my boyfriend said
the same thing he's like because we have
like this app where we fill out like
answers from did you get it yeah yeah so
much fun what compared it's an app for
couples where like it asks a bunch of
questions and then you get to know your
company and you don't get to see your
other persons or you don't they don't
get to see your answer until they answer
it oh yeah and then like
she said he's like I love you so much
that or it was like how would you feel
if your spouse was cheating he's like he
answers like I think I love you so much
that I would try to make it work out and
I was like yeah what no because my
answer is like I will [ __ ] murder you
setting your whole house on fire yeah no
one will find the body yeah I love you
so much I'm gonna try to make it work if
that happens you need to call me because
I will help you set him on fire right
exactly like just so you know you don't
get the same Mercy yeah two different
people here yeah yeah but I'm like
that's so it's weird to understand but
to hear you say it too I'm like wow this
is no I wouldn't absolutely not stay
with him if I found out he was cheating
on me but I would just be so [ __ ]
stunned like because I didn't pull that
off yeah I have such good intuition with
that and like so like even the slightest
[ __ ] thing being off I'm like there's
something wrong here you know and he's
always like how did you know like I was
like sad like I didn't even know I was
sad yeah and uh buddy yeah and so like
like if he was cheating I I'd just be
like Bravo like I don't know how you do
that we're done but like I don't know
how you did that [ __ ] you should
become a spy yeah yeah I think I think
if Steve ever cheated on you it would be
like finding out Bob Ross was a
pedophile yeah you know like why I would
kind of throw my own Mr Rogers yeah I
was like are you sure yeah are you sure
yeah if the girl came up to me and even
like said and like showed me pictures
and video of them doing I'd be like
you're like is he fake
this is a conspiracy
walking Steve balls deep in someone else
like well
maybe yeah
am I cheating
this is a huge compliment to Steve yeah
[Laughter]
he's stupid okay
um he says why did I picture him with
the buttholes
[Laughter]
my imagination was like well look put
that there no one's waiting he's never
even seen his butt it's true and I still
have it it's got a butthole
it's like blurred yeah and then still
you'd be like you know what maybe he's
just testing out our new invention he's
so supportive
husband and it does match his butt
directly over it I think I would be more
mad at the fact like not that he's
cheating on you but that another woman
got to see his butthole yeah yeah you
know like you've never seen his butthole
after a while
[Music]
like that's the highest
trying to like figure it out she's like
having sex he's just bending over and
she's looking at his butt and she's like
you mad at all the doctors I've been
doing proctal exams on him
prostate apologize
um he said I think the fact she
immediately jumped to cheating shows how
bad the relationship is she was waving
the underwear underwear around and I
recognized him because they had a floral
print but I just left you're like I take
those off with my teeth those are my
wife's he doesn't like this your mom
says
[Music]
so he said I just let this ridiculous
fight go on my wife came home after
about 30 minutes and said they were hers
my wife asked if I didn't realize they
were hers and I accidentally laughed
you could have kept it together yeah
sounds like a Paul red movie my daughter
bursts in tears and won't talk to me my
fiance said we're [ __ ] and left the
house but my wife thought it was funny I
don't think the wife likes this guy
because no one likes this guy well [ __ ]
him yeah
she cares about his daughter that's why
yeah
um so is he the [ __ ] for just letting
them fight about it no yeah
no I know I'm conflicted he's the
[ __ ] for sure
yeah
I'm an [ __ ] then yeah I think it's a
Justified [ __ ] [ __ ] situation here
where he's like you know we have those
sometimes where it's like yes you were
an [ __ ] but Justified yeah I don't
know also if I'm a guy I could play dumb
oh he he [ __ ] up he's the [ __ ] for
laughing and like revealing himself yeah
you should just let it go like they
always already have problems in their
relationship they don't trust each other
yeah but that's see the thing is is like
people trying to intervene or by way of
intervening is never the route to go
because obviously they're having issues
and it's not gonna work anymore he's not
intervening he's like I know but he's by
way of intervening right it's like lying
by Omission so it's like
now you're going to ruin your
relationship with your daughter because
you're not letting her like if I've I
was picturing my dad yeah trying to get
rid of a gut my dad's never intervened
even if he's hated every single
boyfriend I've ever had I'm not saying
he has but he's never once been like I
don't like that guy get him out of your
life he's just been like she'll figure
it out you know what I mean so what if
like I told you guys I'm getting back
with my ex the recent one yeah
that we all know chewed on me and you
know we all filmed and then one day we
went home and did laundry and I find
your underwear
and then I'm like what the [ __ ] okay it
has to be the girls I would tell you
it's mine damn it's just come on I need
you I would tell you it's mine and you
need to [ __ ] dump that guy because
yeah I guess yeah because then if in
this Dad situation he could have been
like yeah that's my wife's but also this
is not look at it what are you doing
what is this yeah like look at this one
look at what's happening take a look at
yourselves kids yeah I just like the
drama I don't know what I would have to
get rid of something I want to say I'd
be the person that's like those are my
wives that but I don't know I'm
genuinely like I don't know what I would
do yeah
I guess I'd kind of be an [ __ ] I mean
and if I found out you guys did that I
feel like yeah you're an [ __ ] yeah
but what can you do I don't I wouldn't
want my daughter to look stupid either
like you know like those are those are
those are your moms she looked crazy now
because like you I feel like those are
actually your mom's and she already went
off on him but I don't know which kind
of makes her look like she's just to
prolong it it kind of makes now he has
ammo to be like see you jumped at me
because it was even just like I was your
mom's would ever watch her be ignorant
over something and to let it drag out
that's a good point
yeah I mean it would make her but I
think he was doing it out of like oh
this will finally get rid of him which I
understand you know what this scene
reminds me of the scene here it reminds
me of the scene in uh Breaking Bad where
the girl vomited yeah when the girl's
dying vomiting oh and he could have like
turned her to the side and she could
have been alive but he just let her
drown in her own vomit yeah because he
didn't like her yeah
that was his own selfish kind of reason
but it wasn't for the goodness of Jesse
but yeah yeah
I can't say I wouldn't do this I can't
say it I can't say anything yeah like I
would do that for you guys if I hated
like if he was beating you or something
oh yep so I don't know well if that's
the case I mean if he's like that
terrible then I could see intervening in
some weird way but
like even like knowing that he's like if
what if I wasn't here you know like and
didn't see this let me just pretend I
didn't see you or what about the dad not
doing it in front of the fiance and be
like hey daughter
um can I speak to you really quick I
know you're in the middle of something
but just over here there's something and
be like those are actually
hmm
so also take a look at the fact that you
are quick to accuse him of cheating
maybe this isn't uh someone you should
marry there's something under there as
someone who and you guys know this it
was hard for me to leave such a shitty
relationship that was so clearly shitty
because I had Road sitting classes on
uh I don't think the daughter would
listen to that yeah like it takes
something crazy to like finally leave I
mean other people intervening usually
doesn't work either exactly you got to
just let them figure it out for
themselves yeah but then in that case
though the fiance wouldn't know that
those weren't
like or whatever like that those are the
mom's underwear wouldn't humility the
daughter to the to the fiance but yeah
that's what I'm saying like before the
mom because that had lasted for 30
minutes yeah like before the mom coming
home so anyway it saves the daughter
from being uh from having the fiance
have ammo against her it also lets her
know so then the dad doesn't get um
doesn't lose a relationship with his
daughter I don't know if the ammo thing
works so because they were never someone
else's so like the fact that she thinks
they're someone else's is ammo anyways
like you're crazy you're [ __ ] crazy
those aren't someone else's so at some
point we find out you know why though is
because deep down inside because he's so
shitty and they don't like him I feel
like he he does cheat on her and maybe
he's like he's like I don't even know
yeah
that's what that's what my but also is
the house that they live in with their
parents
I just don't think that it's possible
that it's someone else's like if he's
cheating he's probably going somewhere
else so it's just like she's gonna look
crazy either way because he's making
[ __ ] crazy he's making her crazy
because he sucks his parents see it yeah
but it's just like I don't know there's
no reason for the dad to just like
intervene by not intervening I guess
yeah
yeah I guess for me it's like everyone
else saw it but I didn't until I got
definitive proof that he was cheating
yeah you know then I like got out
um so I don't know like I you know
that's why I'm like maybe
so she finally leaves anyhow uh top
comment says you might be the [ __ ]
but I'm living for it
[Laughter]
um second comment says um
everyone sucks here but including me
because I laughed too
this one says not the [ __ ] if your
first thought is cheating and not the
other woman that lives in this house
you've got issues right that's what I'm
saying like he probably has already
implanted so much insecurities and like
so many clues that he is [ __ ] around
yeah uh not the [ __ ] it's not your
fight either also it's wild that your
daughter would think that her fiance was
bringing girls into your house her own
parents to cheat on and accidentally
leave underwear there that's hilarious
and I would have probably laugh too if I
lived with another woman and the same
thing happened to me I feel like I would
assume they were hers before anything
else my significant other and I keep our
laundry separate and stuff of his still
ends up in mine yeah it says a lot that
she jumped to that yeah yeah
I like that comment everyone sucks here
but including me because I'm also yeah
same uh okay all right here's the last
one am I the [ __ ] for pointing out to
my friends that they are not famous
uh no no
yeah we'll see I mean that always
reminds me of when Lady Gaga what
um in college or whatever she was
bullied to the point where like her
friends were bullying her High School
whatever they made a Facebook group and
she'll never be famous I forgot
Stephanie whatever you will never be
famous yeah that's hilarious I would a
screenshot that print that out and put
in my [ __ ] Mansion well that's one
thing to say you will never be famous
but it's another thing to say you are
currently not famous yeah sit down [ __ ]
am I the [ __ ] for not pointing out or
for pointing out that my friends are not
famous my friends are dating they're
also actors who have had small roles on
a few TV shows I'm talking two lines or
less I say this not to be a hater I
truly am rooting for them but to give
you a scope of their reach neither of
them have a following in real life or on
social media they've got under 1500
followers combined wait what's up oh wow
scrubs yeah 1500 comes mine I've got
more than that and I've never done
anything in my life yeah [ __ ] losers
I'm just kidding no we don't care um
anyway last week I posted a group
picture on Instagram and of people
celebrating a friend's birthday everyone
in the photo has got their arms around
each other's shoulders very platonic
anyways yesterday in a group chat
between the three of us they asked me to
take the photo down because they don't
want quote the public to know that they
are dating
that's really cute how they they think
that that's cute
I would consider if they looked bad
slash too sloppy drunk Etc I get that
but they don't also everyone has their
arms around each other not just them
anyways I asked what they meant they
said they didn't want to end up in the
gossip website oh that's really cute
what
I can't even wrap my head around people
thinking these are the people that have
like 200 followers and like do you know
who I am yeah how can I not get this
manicure for free I have followers I'll
give you exposure but like they don't
even have followers for like that level
no like that's like when you hit 15 000
right you're like like yeah ten thousand
people think like oh yeah
how many followers this is like they
have 1500 yeah like random people on
Tick Tock who get their first million
view Tick Tock and they start looking up
Apartments in La you know yeah not a
good idea calm down
all right um at first I thought like the
public meaning like if they wanted a
family no like if they wanted to network
within the industry sometimes there's a
lot of like behind media scenes Casting
Couch situations that like you want to
look single yeah
um because I know people that yeah but
uh not then when they said the gossip
website
yeah okay I'm with you on that like
maybe if they're trying to up and come
in like agents and stuff will see their
like you're not supposed to say your age
and you're not supposed to say your
dating status someone could still be
looking at their social media profiles
to see if they're single yeah and
whatever but not gossip websites no one
gives them that that's funny career well
wait after all going like you knew
people that would do Cassie Couch kind
of situations why would the person
getting a sexual favor
care if the person it would just be
easier
it's not messy it's less messy like
they're not going to get offended
because they have a boyfriend or
something yeah I don't know it's just
you're already being shitty like what
does it matter it's just I feel like
they target easy people right a single
person is easier to Target I mean like
they do get a lot everyone's a dime a
dozen why wait why would you choose to
hit on the one with the with a blockade
of a boyfriend yeah when you can hit hit
on the one that doesn't have a boyfriend
true you know all right so I pointed out
that they are not famous and that they
don't even have functioning IMDb pages
hahaha
wait what does that mean functioning
there's nothing on there dude I even
[ __ ] have one I've never done
anything and everything on there isn't
correct I don't understand I who made it
and I don't know what are they weird
um they were livid and called me a bunch
of names I think they're delusional but
they've been texting me demanding it and
even sent me screenshots of them
reporting it nothing's happened to the
photo wait that's sad it doesn't sound
like real friends here yeah these people
are weird I thought when you were saying
they sent me screenshots I thought of
the gossip places oh like at least like
they're legitimate sort of yeah
screenshots of them they're like mid
report they're like
like I'm gonna report it
I need both fingers to do this yeah at
this point I don't even want to be their
friend however and probably because I'm
an [ __ ] I don't want to delete it
yeah based solely on principle am I the
[ __ ] don't delete it and stop being
friends yep I agree
I don't know I'm kind of with y'all on
this one oh when I went on the same
wavelength of petty this yeah I might
I'm like I'm willing to be the [ __ ]
but I don't know if it'll like create
more problems where like they start
doing something to create problems in
your life like maybe the joke's over now
it's funny like just cut them off and
maybe take it down but like
I'm kind of with you on that yeah I for
me it's like it's a grip photo that
everyone is having fun like Memories
good love or whatever and these two asks
for that reason yeah I don't even know
if I even want the photo with them
anymore like when I kind of cut people
out I'm like [ __ ] you and all the photos
we have archive archive archive archives
like I'm just like get out I don't know
extra layer of petty delete the photo
but re-upload it with like their faces
blocking out and caption says sorry guys
I have to block out these faces because
they're famous celebrities and nobody
like they don't want them being on the
gossip pages
they create a real
yes I put the music behind it just
contact the gossip websites and say
these people think they're famous enough
that you would care that they're in a
relationship together is there an
article on that yeah
written about it yeah the email comes
back I'm sorry we don't know who these
people are upload that [ __ ] too
you know this is a hate page on that
company I'm searching the name I'm gonna
get more followers
verified so that's Gina's approach okay
yeah we're ready to start on irrelevant
people thinking there yeah
um
what are you thinking about yeah
just like make like a fake TMZ article
and upload it yeah
and then send them screenshot be like oh
man you guys there's no comments yeah oh
my God it's still cold probably ruined
your career though probably like
okay okay so is this person the [ __ ]
or no no no no no no no okay top comment
says and consent consensus says everyone
sucks here uh since they ask you to take
a picture of them off social media you
should have done that that being said
they're acting pretty ridiculous for
their quote Fame
uh uh yeah I get that like if someone
says can you take that down yeah
regardless of
but I don't think you're an [ __ ] for
like leaving it up a little bit longer
just to kind of poke at them yeah just
to kind of poke it in but then go ahead
and take it down I think okay yeah you
should take it down when someone
requests yeah because that's what I hope
it's like privacy yeah yeah but you're
not an [ __ ] for telling them they're
not famous yeah at all yeah that's the
party yeah that's fine uh someone else
says everyone sucks here they have
inflated egos however you should take
down a photo and ask to take it down
regardless of the reason okay we can
agree on that yeah so do take down the
photo but you're not an [ __ ] for
telling them that yeah okay guess we got
that one
case I know right and then next time
they come out in like a extra roll or
something they're so famous yeah I think
my cat has more followers
please don't post pictures of my cat
without permission all right uh that's
been an episode of big mood doing am I
the [ __ ] I hope you guys enjoyed that
and uh let us know who you think is that
yeah your [ __ ] would like
it would be very uncomfortable but just
think about the utility yeah let's work
on the name yeah actually comment your
name suggestions for this project
comment what color you thought it was
gonna be you can imagine it a whole new
world do you think Steve would wear
the
world
um no but I actually you make me whole
yeah
okay so make sure you guys check out our
you're thinking about buttholes aren't
you you can't talk cause you're thinking
about buttholes yeah
um okay so make sure you guys check out
our uh our sponsors in the description
box and give us a like follow subscribe
thumbs up rate US five stars on iTunes
animals don't take pictures and tag us
yeah I'm very famous we're Super Famous
okay they don't want like gossip
magazines I want people to know I'm
married to a man that won't show me his
butt
all right see you guys later bye
[Music]